كل عام وكل امراه تشعر نفسها افضل اكثر
نجاحا واكثر قدره على الانجاز انا اليوم
حاحكي او اوجه تحيه لاول رائده فضاء
السعوديه هي ريانه
يعني عملت
الحقيقه صدمه ايجابيه جدا بين النساء في
السعوديه والسبب هو انه المهمه اللي تقوم
فيها اليوم لم يحدث ان قامت بها اي امراه
في السعوديه ابدا على الاطلاق في الكل
يعلق اعماله على ان يتبع ريانه الى هذا
الانجاز وهو طبعا انها اول سيده السعوديه
تكلف بمهمه الى الفضاء وحتكون ان شاء الله
مدتها عشر ايام في مهمه اسمها اي اكس ات
تو برغم انه ريانا دراستها بالماجستير
وبالبكالوريوس كانت بعلم الطب الحيوي مشمل
بالعلوم الفضائيه وكده لكنها بعدين درست
علوم الفضاء والتكنولوجيا واصبحت مؤهله
لهذا الانتاج واكيد المراه الى الفضاء هذا
الشيء نفخر به نحن كنساء يسوها ويسعد
صباحك كمان اليوم في صباح وكل عام وانت
بالف خير صباحك يا رب سهى ومن جدا معكم
الى بيروت الى البترون بالتحديد شمال
لبنان يسعد هالصباح من البترون لرينا
دويهي رنا بالانتخابات اللبنانيه الاخيره
كان في كتير تعويل على التغيريين انه
اقلوا يحققوا مساله المساواه بين المراه
والرجل خصوصا هذا الجدل الشائك حول وضع
المراه اللبنانيه في لبنان اليوم ماذا
تقولين في ذلك
نعم بلبنان البطلات كتار وبكل المجالات
المراه موجوده رغم كل الحقوق المنقوصه
وانا اخترت اليوم على سبيل المثال للحصر
الدكتور نجاه صليبه هي اتيه من المجال
العلمي ومتخصصه في يعني التلوث البيئي
ومشاكل البيئه حسب 2019 كانت على لائحه
النساء الاكثر تاثيرا في العالم على يعني
لائحه بي بي سي لانها وصلت كما تقولين الى
الندوه البرلمانيه عبر صفوف التغرير
التغيريين ونجاه صليبه تبيت اليوم منذ
اكثر من شهر ونصف تحت قبه البرلمان
اللبناني دون كهرباء ودون تدفئه نعم هي
اقرت اعتصاما مفتوحا هي وزميلها النائب
ملحم خلف
اعتصاما مفتوحا لحين انتخاب رئيس
للجمهوريه ومن ذلك الحين نجاه صليبه باقيه
في المجلس لا تغادره الا للاستحمام وعند
الضروره تتداول مع زميلتها حليمه قعقور
على المبيت ويتعاون زملائه من النواب
التغيريين على مدهم بالاساسيات من الطعام
ومن الملبس واهم من كل شيء من شحن
[موسيقى]
كتبت وكتبت فلم يبقى حرف وسفت وصفت فلم
يبقى وصف اقول اذا باختصار
بلادي نساء ونصف بهذه الابيات للشاعر
العظيمه التونسي الصغيره اولاد احمد
احييكم
وكل زميلات في صباح العربيه وفي قناه
العربيه ونحيي المراه عبر العالم الكادحات
الصميدات القويات المتميزات وانس جابر خير
مثالا لهن اليوم بطلتي في يوم المراه
العالمي هي انس جابر التي جاءت من عائله
متوسطه لتقتحم رحاب رياضه الاثرياء فغيرت
قوانينها يعني بصفه مجازيه وجعلتها انظار
العالم تنطلق وتثبت على تونس وعلى العرب
وعلى القاره الافريقيه بمضربها في
ويمبلدون انس جابر صنعت التاريخ وحققت
انجازا كان الى وقت قريب حكرا على نساء
وعلى شعوب اخرى انس جابر لا تغيب عن العمل
الخيري لا تغيب عن ترميم المدارس لتغيب عن
الشح ذي ممم الاطفال الصغار بان يصنعوا
بدورهم
بطولتهم وان يصنعوا حلمهم وقصتهم الجميله
لانس جابر ولكل امراه متميزه وجريئه في
يوم المراه العالمي وفي كل يوم كل تحيه
والف تحيه واجمل التحيه لكن زميلتي في
صباح العربيه المتميز دائما بالاطلاله
النسويه مع القياده ايضا النسويه والذكريه
المشتركه نحي الجميع يعني احلام احسنت
احسنتي وعجزنا عن الرد والوصف لما قلت